he's the baddest man on the planet he's
the heavyweight champion of the world
it's francis and ganu on this week's
food truck diaries
and he we booked him really short notice
so we couldn't get him a food truck so i
went and picked up chicken sandwiches
and we got them out of the trunk of my
car
this week's food truck diaries with
francis and gano let's go
from my wallet to my check i don't want
it if it's skinny but i need it
[Music]
what's up big dog you looking great
brother thank you you ain't coming here
limping or nothing man you look good
uh yeah i was i'm still limping you're
still in pain that the knee's in pain uh
it was is what you it's not even my knee
i get i kick with this leg okay you know
yeah get a little kick on that yeah it's
a little soreness but and did we get uh
answers from the doc like how
like the are you out six months a year
do we know yet or is it still up in the
air no i need the acs surgery okay so
that and uh after during the ac are they
gonna see if they need to reattach the
mcl or if he's gonna
reattach himself so big boy big boy
surgery
this is my thing man going into this
fight if you watch the shop show i
preach this
you weren't just fighting for the world
heavyweight title against cyril gone who
to me is
maybe beside you the most athletic
heavyweight his movements ridiculous has
never been taken down doesn't have a
loss
so not only fighting for that but then
what you represent for the first ever uh
title holder to not recent resign bank
on yourself
all that's already pressure and then i
find out you have one leg and you still
want to take the fight even though the
your camp was like i think it's a bad
idea man i'm sure your boy's like it's a
bad idea man just explain to me that the
biggest night of your life you're going
on
really not even close to 100
you know what i'm saying so how like
what kind of mental capacity were you at
going into the fight
well uh mental capacity i think that was
my most strength like i was very in a
good space mentally because like uh
three weeks and a half ago when i get my
injury
i was pretty good uh physically
and uh
during after that time i kind of like
been into like a dark
position like darling about if i can
fight or not yeah you know then i
remember like one day i spoke to uh
camaro he was in africa
and then he all reminds me about like
all this because i've been around him
for five weeks multiple times and then i
don't mind uh he reminds me everything
that he's been through he's growing his
kneecap all those stuff like camaro's
knees are super messed up man then i'm
like
yeah i can't i can do it yeah you know
because with
being with him in the five weeks knowing
all what's going on on you i'm like why
he didn't he didn't call out this fight
yeah then he go
he he go out there and you see the
performance that he executed you know
i'm like [ __ ]
like something must be happening in
there yeah i think that's the moment
that i'd be shy like i'm not calling
this fight yeah he really inspired me at
that time i'm like i'm not calling this
fight out i know like uh he's been going
through fight without three was sparring
and that's exactly what's happened to me
because after this my knee was so messed
up i couldn't even striking the first
week i couldn't do it it was after like
uh
one week that i could like hit me
properly i was just doing like a bike
then i could hit me but since then uh
all my uh training cam schedule uh fell
apart wrestling
just crapping grappling i couldn't do
anything because when i was even trying
to like random pound the position wasn't
good at all like i just quit on that but
i know that that night i gonna go there
and it's gonna be that day that i need
to give everything in that octagon and
then if i have to left that leg in the
octagon yeah then walk out with a
victory i'm gonna do it but i better say
kudos to you man it's inspiring it
really it's insane it's insane when
you're in the locker room
with and your shout to your coach uh
nick sick was he ever like all right man
you know let's let's make sure we we
hide the legs after you have two knee
braces on so that he won't know which
leg to do but then the grappling because
you know it's nothing
nobody knows out there listening to this
or watching this it's like you're not a
grappling specialist so was the game
plan to take him down like was that
always the game plan no he wasn't always
the game plan he was
a paddle it was an option you know i was
yes i was very uh confident about my
wrestling and my ground and my uh
grabble you know i was very confident
about that so i think that's even the
reason why like i took that uh i took
that ground in the fight because like uh
for the first round he initiated the uh
the tip down
yes he initiated that then i'm like well
really you really want to do this you
know and that was a perfect situation
for me because being on the ground
obviously my knee hurt a little bit but
i wasn't uh
concerned that he can like collapse yeah
you know like i can sleep and then he
fall apart or something i know that i'm
sitting down so in my heart but
not
i'll be okay you know so when i started
to get in that position basically after
the uh
second round you know i knew that it
wasn't on my favor i couldn't move i was
just thinking about my knee trying to do
anything i want to switch so i'm like oh
if he gets me kicked my knee let's go
back like if i sleep or eat if these you
know
very meant the two first round was very
challenging it was a fight with yourself
yes i was fighting with myself debating
like oh man
was it the right decision to come to
this fight yeah with this knee you know
debating then after the by the end of
the situation i'm like man screw this
there's too much on the line there's too
much people uh counting on me on this
fight basically i understand i've been
receiving a lot of love and support from
my home country oh yeah i'm like pro
i don't have to let them down i'm giving
everything here then i walk in the third
round like screwed everything and you
won every round
out yeah and by the end of the third
round i look at him i go there on the
third round like okay give everything
and uh by the end of the third round
i'll look at him and
you can tell he wasn't the same you can
tell i can't tell i thought
i'm like i don't recognize that look
yeah that was me when i fought first
first for stephen you know i know
exactly yeah they don't want to be in
there or they realize they're in trouble
yeah i'm like he was just like what the
[ __ ] am i doing here yeah i'm like come
on he was like i would tell you what
you're doing yeah
i am not ready for this it's not stuff
like it's not snowflake
[Laughter]
when you're taking him down in the
corner he looks and he goes we got some
now don't you we do i'm like oh [ __ ]
it's on it's so on
um
it's just it's so inspirational but we
knew we knew like uh the first two round
if we go past if we go past two round
the first two rounds gonna be the
toughest because it's gonna be fresh
it's gonna be moving yes
everything was to like apply pressure
get him constantly in the in pressure
even though we might take some damage
but he's going to get tired he's not
used to bugs on his heels you know he's
used like two people stand there so he
can uh
jump jump dodge jump jump touch you know
but when you constantly apply pressure
you can
just do that for five rounds so after
two rounds
i'm like yeah
it might be
slowing down at this time you can
initiate wrestling and all this stuff
you know he's not as fresh as he was
yeah he was before so it's a little
easier about that time uh was this the
happiest you've ever been after when
oh man how did you go into it i was
relieved like you know
i feel like
i had a truck
on my on my head
i was just relieved like
and then i'm like oh we're gonna fight
let's go party i'm like bro leave me i'm
it like right now in my mind it's a body
yeah i'm cheating i'm good you know i'm
good yeah
like i didn't care about anything at
that time like how could you and then
well i'll feed you after this at least
we have some time so she have knee
surgery for you to eat delicious food
and so you get off your diet today but
i'll before we get food
with the there was a lot of hype around
the training footage you guys were
training partners yeah
being a former fighter people would ask
me would you see the training foot and i
go i don't care
come up to quote allen iverson talk
about practice not my practice
i need to know what happened that was
did did francis do five rounds with
somebody else and he jumped in
what was the what was the i need to know
just came from a vacation that's what
i'm saying oh what's up that's what i'm
saying is friends
with him yeah that's what i'm saying
like i i need to there's there's other
things as someone who's an insider and
i've been there where some new kid came
in the gym you know i maybe i was out
the night before i'm not in camp i was
like yeah i'll work with him if they're
filming he lights him up like oh that
dude lit him up it's like yeah but i was
in that's not real like yeah i'm talking
about practice so i didn't put any
only that like that footage wasn't a
full footage though i mean he was a clip
on the footage because if they lay out
that training uh footage it wasn't going
on his favor and i think that's why they
couldn't send out uh the whole footage i
didn't know that no i don't care about
it it was good hype for the fight yes me
too i'm like i don't care about
i i go to the gym uh i spy with girls
you know like yeah play with them yeah
yeah she hits you you know just interact
like this keep training i spell with 1
55 and 170 sure 70 and you know uh just
to have some good work make them put you
in some position apply pressure get your
footwork you know to know how to uh
work your cage control because that's
what you're doing yeah you know and uh
even if at the end you spot with
somebody and end up like hurt him or
knock him out you know you feel bad
because the mistake you hurt your
sparring problems you shouldn't be doing
that it's not something that you're
proud of no you know you feel bad about
and it's not the thing that you walk out
there i'm like oh i knock him out in the
sparring you know how we were aspiring
and knock him out no not getting paid
for it you're a douchebag yeah you know
that's that's not how it works you feel
bad because that wasn't a goal yep yeah
i didn't put any energy in that training
footage well let me feed you and have a
million questions let me feed you real
quick
[Music]
all right francis it's called food truck
diaries but because we butch on short
notice a lot of food trucks can do it on
a day's notice so i wouldn't pick the
food up for you and this is my ride and
i think you'll be able to afford
about 30 of these after your next deal
but i got
you better be able to i can feed on this
you'll fit in it man i'm a huge guy and
i got you but what we did is we got you
some chicken sandwiches to celebrate
this big win
they're in here
it looks good it's tasty
you can have a little down time with
this knee so i feel like you can chow
that's just to hold it up hollywood
stuff but let me feed you the food's
inside
it's gonna be tasty though man so let's
eat and let's chat some more it's good
that i have fight yeah right i got you
man
not bad yeah
they're doing good ryan let's do it man
let me feed you doug a champion's meal
here
let's take a little break from chatting
with the baddest man on the planet
francis singano cause listen y'all it's
2022 and you're looking for something to
get in shape with you're sick of the gym
you're sick of working out with your
buddies you're sick of just pumping iron
well my friends at peloton they got you
covered man with the peloton bike man
they got so much more to offer you think
it's just a bike with a trainer you're
wrong son they got new classes new music
new ways to keep your workouts fun and
motivating if you're trying to stick to
work out you can't just do the same
thing over and over that's why peloton
makes it great and they're offering new
things for the new year we're talking
about boxing man you want to knock
people out like francis and gano when i
mean knock it out i mean
from your living room and you can
pretend that you're knocking out stipe
or some of these other fighters he's
knocked out you can do that and you can
do it with peloton belt on boxing
they're stepping into the ring man with
the newest discipline no gloves needed
all right even if you've never boxed
before but you're francis and gano fam
we got you covered man you're throwing
combos you got footwork form
fundamentals keep you on your toes they
got new music new artists man from hip
hop pop rock edm we got it all man they
have uh all sorts of new workouts we're
talking about 20 minutes of cardio 15
minutes with total body you can do yoga
meditation dance cardio get your freak
on man if this pal tom workout sounds
like something for you all you got to do
is go to one peloton.com that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com that's
onepelton.com
that's a wrap on the nfl playoffs and
hopefully the team you're cheering for
got in but if they didn't it's all good
can still make bank on the super ball
here in los angeles california but you
got to do it at one place one place only
we're talking about draftkings all right
and if you're not a new customer it's
all good man they got great bets for new
for existing customers if you can bet on
the super bowl do a parlay man combine
multiple bets from the same game for a
bigger payout the more likes you add the
more money you win your boys the parlay
master draftkings is safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit
withdrawal your cash whenever you want
man download the draftking sportswik app
right now use promo code shobb all right
you shop if you're in bed on the super
ball you gotta use the promo code shop
get them boosted parlays get those
boosted odds for the super ball coming
up right here in los angeles california
again that's promo coach schaab at
draftking sportsbook the official sports
band partner the nfl must be 21 or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only minimum five dollar
deposit one dollar wager required
gambling problem cool call 1-800 gambler
um let me ask you this man in a uh
off seat you're
you know going to this fight the mac do
the fight the pressure first time ever a
heavyweight champ didn't resign you
notice you have all that pressure going
to fight you have one leg
you win the fight
obviously you know i'm not saying to
anybody that watches a show or that your
team or anybody out there doesn't know
dana doesn't put the belt on you you
know i don't know if you notice that
inside the office but mig
would you say me nick yeah he did he put
him yeah mick maynard he put the bed on
me he's a nice guy i love him yeah i
like him too i really like him
um
how
in your eyes what's a perfect scenario
like how do you see this playing out
i'll tell you what i want to happen but
i'd rather you want me to go first or
you want to go first go first go first
okay
my idea would be in a perfect world and
i have no idea about the the details of
this my in a perfect world the ufc would
pay you what you're worth
and they would be a partner when you go
on to fight tyson fury and deontay
wilder anthony joshua
and those fights are there but the ufc
who's great at marketing right they're
the best in the world marketing
so they get behind you you get the hype
machine behind the ufc when you fight
tyson fury and deonte water who will be
next and anthony joshua all that's there
for you but it's with the ufc and well
they'll get their share they'll make
their money
but then also to that point you're still
the heavyweight champion
and
you know you can still fight jon jones
and steve or whoever's next so to me if
i'm the ufc right i'm in the meeting
today they go all right
so what do you want to do with francis
and
in that entire board meeting everyone
should go well what should be next for
francis why john jones is down to fight
him which would be our biggest
heavyweight fight of all time we'd make
money on that right yeah i'd make mine
then all right cool let's do that and
then after that
uh tyson fury really wants to find him
we'd make all the money in the world
doing that right yeah i would do that so
he has a good showing or beats them then
we're going tyson fury ty's fury rematch
anthony joshua deante walter we're
making more money than god so let's
figure out how to give
francis something that he's happy with
is that possible or am i just
am i'm
because i believe that the ufc is like a
very
big
ufc machine second of known so uh
as far as promoting
they are really good at their job you
know
but uh
i think
they need to be on board to be able to
promote something they need to really
be willing to do that agree and that's
what we've been uh trying to pitch to
the ufc in the
past two years my team been working on
that
but
apparently like uh it's really tough to
get something uh done with me with them
uh right now because even before the
stippy fight
they were promoting the uh
the promise that the winner of stephen i
will fight john jones yeah but right
after i win that fight
nobody never speak about that friday
it seems like they didn't want money to
be me why do you think that is
because i didn't sign a contract
so they don't want to you think if they
don't invest something that they're
worried that you're just going to leave
maybe
or
maybe they don't they don't want to give
you
like what could be your best fight
without having something in return yes
which is like a deal yes
yeah so
you know let's say
if that unfortunately didn't work out
the
the goal would be obviously the tyson
fury fight but when it comes to mma
where would you land if ufc is not home
you know obviously the tyson fury stuff
is there the wilder joshua is potential
so boxing you're covered
but if you have that would you even need
mma you know what i'm saying
if you have
all the riches in the world doing
fighting ties and fury in the rematch
types and fury and god knows what else
you're gonna go on to do after that do
you even need to fight for another
promotion it's not ufc
um would you want to
i would
like to fight mma you know it's a sport
that i love to do yeah i think it's a
passion you know uh
and
maybe not for some promotion but uh
maybe some charity match uh stuff like
that
you know but i would definitely still
have to yeah do something on this stuff
you know i really wanna like see how um
how far i can go in this how much i can
still learn what is like uh
the uh limit for me as far as said yes
experience yeah what is the ceiling yeah
in the mma you know because i feel yeah
i'm a champion but i feel like there's a
lot of room for me to improve a lot of
way for me to go in the sport uh himself
so i'm really excited about that
even during the training camp
you know i get very my last two training
camera i get very excited to see how i
can learn like film like get back i love
the train i love being there like i was
there like after training uh i would do
like maybe a running treadmill or
jump rope for like 30 minutes 40 minutes
and i just feel like there's no place
that i'd rather be than be there you
know like you love it i want to do this
yeah i want
you know uh
i get excited when i show up in every at
every practice
even when i'm tired because it might be
the second section of the day
or the end of the week uh and my body is
kind of like exhausted but i just get
excited that adrenaline i'm a passion
for it i'm passionate about it so i can
i can't let him
let it down go right now
yeah you know i feel like i still have a
lot to give
you more than i have done already i
started what you've done a lot but when
you look at the division
you know i'm you know a steep a rematch
maybe there's that for you but then the
rubber fight with ebay but then really
the only one out there that if you want
to prove something yourself would be jon
jones there's always a fight yeah listen
uh
when i first tp
syrian gang wasn't even in the last
landscape correct but for somehow he
became like the big the obvious thing to
do yeah you know and uh in three months
you don't know we're gonna be out there
and be the
contender yeah the number one contender
so there's uh there will always be
someone to fight
so that's not even when you look at that
jon jones fight do you look at it it
excites you do you see where you have
advantages i've really get excited about
that fight for over a year since i
fought uh giazino i think that was
uh
almost two years ago now
yeah and uh
you know get excited about it but uh
what is the how what is the possibility
for from getting that fight done
also uh there is a usa on the other side
and there's john john himself or on
other side a lot would have to have so
like it happened a lot have to happen so
but i don't think it would happen that i
don't know yeah i think
like you know with the ufc i know it's a
business but just for a legacy like they
have to figure it out like for the fans
they owe it to us to figure that out
like if you and jon jones don't fight
for the heavyweight belt it's it's such
a shame and so and for what for money
why why i first fought for uh again uh
syria again uh uh instead of john jones
which was the thing that was promised uh
from who was promised after you beat
stephen yeah
yeah i don't know if that's a jon jones
prom i don't know if they just don't
want to invest because they're where
you're gonna leave you know i don't know
i don't there's a lot of you know it's
just a lot of to put it frankly [ __ ]
it really is man and it's such a shame
so that's exactly what i have to deal
with every single day yeah
and it's a lot do you feel pressure with
dealing with it
no i mean i used to i used to feel
pressure about it but uh i get to the
point that
you know i'm just happy i'm satisfied uh
and as i said before
uh at this point i'm happy uh
from what i have done you know and from
the life that i have people around me my
family
that's
yeah that's good enough for me to be
happy and as i said
if this is the end let it be as far as i
uh as much as i want everything out
there
i'm still okay with what i have now
you've done all right man yeah you've
done all right and i i would say
this and i'll end on this i think
you know when it whenever a fighter
leaves a camp so when you left your your
old coach and you went to las vegas i
you know it's it's always dicey you know
you're banking on that coach and nick
sick and stuff like that of doing the
right thing i think no fight has ever
validated a fighter for making a change
in camp in this fight because i don't
know
and it's not a knock in your old camp
but i don't know if you would have had
the
the fundamentals the the mindset to go
to grappling when you had one leg if you
would have stayed in france so for me
you win this fight in training with nick
sick it showed that you made the right
decision do you feel that
uh yeah
i mean it validates the decision my i
never doubt my decision but i think like
mindset is not something that you train
you're either born with it or you're not
are you either born with it you didn't
have it or you don't okay
period you don't train for my how do you
if you if you mean for do this stuff
you you do it and if you're not you're
not you know like uh and i uh remember
like when i get in this position was
debating with myself because uh
don't get me wrong it's not like it was
easy he was tough though
he was a lot of questioning about
yourself like oh should i do this could
i do this
what is it going to be an excuse of d or
this you know trying to
debating with yourself and uh
i have to like
kind of like go back to myself like
whenever do i ever give up uh
like i have overcome so many things that
this even seem
small you know in comparison of what um
i have been through a lot more for a lot
less
than now yeah you know so
at the end i'm like yeah yeah this is
something that i
i have it i just have to find it in me
and then go out there with yeah i i
don't think people realize the magnitude
of what you and your agent markel you
guys are doing because it's never been
done before
so i think i was so nervous for you
because if you lost this and markel if
you would have lost this fight man
it's not it's not it wouldn't be good
i'll put it frank you know what i'm
saying like you
your negotiation power the tyson fury
fight like all that kind of goes to the
side you know if you would have lost but
you think you would just
you it'd have been different francis you
know what i'm saying you you would have
been
different for sure yes but uh
i wouldn't be out of option though no no
you're always gonna be no anyone would
gladly take it the ufc would still
resign you it's just for the goal that
you're trying to attain you had to win
that fight
had to yeah for that magnitude yes
the win was always uh better than uh
hell yeah
there was also like uh it's not like
the loss was taking everything out of it
yes it was taking something out take
some wind out of your sails yeah yeah
for sure but and i thought what was that
we thought about it a lot we kind of
like put everything we sat down put
everything in balance i'm like okay what
are we risking yeah what are we gaining
here
but um
personally like this fight for me he was
more like
to make a point you know hell yeah kind
of like to beat the oats yes i love that
challenge like i'm proving you guys well
you know i think if everything would
have be right and perfect i'm not sure
if i would have win this fight yeah you
know yeah you needed to face the
university that adversity that challenge
that
that thing that hit your pride and i'm
like screw this i'm getting yeah i'm
doing this yeah you know because like
even when i remember we were uh when we
took this fight
we were like
you know we we always sit down and
debate about stuff uh with team marker
and others like
and the biggest question on the table
was like what do we have to get into
this right we are turning uh fight a
contract down and we are still taking
fight to go defend the title for six
hundred thousand like that's not even
worth it um
and
but we came out of that like this is not
for money it's right like you have to
forget the
you have to forget the financial part
this is way more bigger than the money
like when you look at this
yes
he has nothing to gain when you think
about money but if you take the money
out there's too much in this fight oh
it's going to change the game forever
yeah what you guys are doing is going to
change the game forever bro forever
it's insane we were right on that you're
right once again we we we sat down
collect ourselves and took the right
decision and made it paid off and people
love that it's inspirational i think
what else is
you know tyson fury immediately after
your win is tweeting out like doesn't
fear he's into it oh he was he was
tweeting he was going over the fight
even before the fight i was so
embarrassed i'm like man i have a fight
getting one bebop
i gotta
lose focus here you know
but
yeah he wants it he's foaming yeah at
the mouth but after the fight i'm pretty
cool i have chill we have time you have
a lot of time we got to go back
take care of that knee eat this chicken
well man i can't tell you you know i've
told markel this your agent but what you
guys are doing is it's never been done
before man and nobody roots for you guys
harder and uh gosh damn i'm so proud of
you man and a happy for your win and i
can't wait to see what's next and uh
yeah man you're crushing champ thank you
very much thank you thank you sean the
champ
on earth but before you go man i uh you
did come here in sandals and i'm a
sneaker head
and so it wasn't easy to track these
down and i got a shoe for you to rock
you're a big guy so i have to think
about comfort so these shoes are for you
they're the sake sakai and nike collab
and the vaporizers because you vaporize
people and these these are hard to find
for a big guy you have a japanese
company that collabs
and now i haven't put red laces in them
so it actually represents the flag of
your your home country so they're comfy
you got rock sandals on now let's go
ahead and burn those and we can put
those on doug
so this is just for you man thank you
very much and when your knees better
those would be good to run in good with
jeans you're gonna fly flying back to
africa in those man they're dope so this
is for running those are for whatever
you get
you can't run in them but i'd wear jeans
with them like they'd look dope with
that it's a comfy shoe for a big dude
man
so uh yeah yeah yeah man those are for
you brother thank you very much
you got it champ enjoy those
thanks the champs
[Music]
i don't want it if it's skinny but i
need it if it's fit
need a thick girl
i need everything i get super thick